[Music]
oh hey you're up high in a dorm room
yeah I folded your pants for you great
know what don't show this sneaky little
[ __ ] maybe you should push the water
next time super helpful
don't be late few parties name okay bye
tree happy birthday got a flipbook money
I got it scared me hey yeah look I know
this isn't gonna make any sense stop
global warming yeah I feel like I'm
losing my mind
you sneaky little [ __ ] happy birthday
I've already lived through this day
[Music]
so you can hear now is everything okay
assuming that I believe any of this is
even possible Frank where's Karl on the
way I see you have unlimited amount of
lives unlimited opportunities to solve
their own murder
someone's supposed to keep dying until I
figure out who my killer is you want to
live a see tomorrow right whoever's
killing you knows it's your birthday
pretty much the entire school is these
are signs of major whom you should be
dead you relive the same day over and
over again I just start to see who you
really are
[Applause]
[Music]